a puerta cerrada los líderes del mundo
las personas más poderosas discuten en
este momento cómo será la recuperación
económica del mundo después de la
pandemia
insistirán en la importancia de que los
países en desarrollo puedan tener acceso
a las vacunas rápidas y se espera que
esta cumbre del g7 salga al compromiso
sólido de que estos países donen un
billón de vacunas para los países en
desarrollo la organización mundial para
la salud ha insistido en que este número
es importante pero será insuficiente
boris johnson y los otros líderes del
mundo hablarán de la importancia de la
educación y que los niños puedan
recuperar las clases y puedan volver lo
más pronto posible y también
especialmente las niñas para acabar así
con ese ciclo de violencia y con ese
ciclo de pobreza en todo el mundo
esperemos a ver entonces y esas mil
millones de vacunas llegan a los países
más pobres gracias a luisa por la
intervención